shane long feu d'origine a des traits
nidal et eb go est également connu sous
le nom d'abou saad un trait ni daddy
selon les documents envoyés au
gouvernement trinidadien par les
services secrets américains
shane crawford âgée de 31 ans sert
d'interprète à l'organisation terroriste
die h il est également agent de
propagande en 2011 qu'on fed avait été
interpellé à acciona d'adp lorsque la
police a dévoilé un complot pour
assassiner le premier ministre de
l'époque kamla persad ça ça aujourd'hui
leader de l'opposition mais manque de
preuves
chen crawford a été libéré aujourd'hui
loin de kandahar et tobago il est
désigné terroriste international ces
biens ont été saisis et ses comptes gelé
malgré son éloignement chaîne cros fun
appelle les traits et d'indiens à
commettre des actes de violence contre
les non croyants sur le sol de trinidad
et tobago